Game of Thrones is about to reach its
epic conclusion but if you're not one of
those people who spent the better part
of the last decade constantly watching
the series for clues you need a
last-second reminder to catch you up or
you know nothing including what that
references it's time to cram all of Game
of Thrones into one handy video well not
all all sorry Mirri Maz Duur fans and
hot pie enthusiasts some stuff had to
get cut away and yes this is a long
video but hey we're about to cram 7
season 67 episodes and a mythology
denser than the hardback version of a
Storm of Swords into less than an hour I
can memorize every time some kind of a
break before we dive into all the
quote-unquote present-day action let's
do a little bit of Game of Thrones 101
the entire show is largely set on a
continent named Westeros which is
divided into several parts collectively
referred to as the Seven Kingdoms the
weather strange in Westeros summers last
months or even years but are followed by
harsh winters which bring darkness and
misery at the northern edge of Westeros
is the wall a giant wall wall built to
keep out all manner of supernatural
creatures primarily the thought to be
extinct White Walkers who can reanimate
corpses to become undead White's also
living north of the wall are a group of
uncivilized folk called wildlings down
south is King's Landing seat of power
for the Seven Kingdoms and home to the
royal family of Westeros for centuries a
family called the Targaryen rule the
land largely because they were able to
conquer the kingdoms and keep power
using dragons kind of like How to Train
Your Dragon but the realistic version of
what people would do with destructive
fire lizards over the years though the
Dragons slowly disappeared and so did
the Targaryen power the last Targaryen
ruler was Ares ii also known as the mad
king who over the course of his reign
lost his mind and became a radical
tyrant who liked to burn people alive
the Targaryen dynasty came crashing down
when Rhaegar Targaryen Eris's son
kidnapped a woman named Leon a stark of
Winterfell sistered Eddard Stark and
betrothed of Robert Baratheon
Robert declared war on the Targaryen and
killed Rhaegar in battle
Liyana also died during the conflict
robert's rebellion ended with Mad King
Aerys dead at the hand of Jaime
Lannister his own Kingsguard and Robert
on the throne as king of Westeros the
remaining Targaryen swerte down and
killed save for viserys and danerys two
of Eris's children who fled east across
the sea Robert was power married to
Cersei Lannister daughter of the richest
family in Westeros and Eddard returned
home to Winterfell to rule as warden of
the north and things are relatively
quiet which is where the show Game of
Thrones really begins ok enough
backstory what the series kicks off
north of the wall were three members of
the Nights Watch sworn protectors of
Westeros from everything beyond the wall
have a run-in with a supernatural white
Walker a bit further south in Winterfell
we meet the rest of the stark family
Eddard Ned Stark who we know his wife
Catelyn and their five children Robb
flexiblelom Sansa Arya bran and Rickon
there's also Ned's bastard son Jon Snow
not to stop an Theon Greyjoy the eldest
living son of Lord Balin Greyjoy of the
Iron Islands Theon was taken as a
hostage during his father's failed
uprising against Westeros and has been
raised by Ned as his ward each of the
stark children also have their own pets
abnormally large wolves called dire
wolves Ned's mentor Jon Arryn known as
the hand of the king pretty much royal
chief of staff has died under semi
questionable circumstances King Robert
decides the job should be Ned Stark's
and he travels to Winterfell along with
his wife Cersei Lannister Circe's
brother Jaime Lannister the Kingslayer
and their brother the hard-drinking
prostitute loving dwarf Tyrion Lannister
to make the arrangements once in
Winterfell Robert convinces Ned to take
the gig by promising to marry his son
Joffrey next in line to the throne to
Ned's daughter Sansa also loyalty
Brotherhood blah blah blah anyway
unfortunately young bran stark who loves
climbing Winterfell Towers spots Jaime
and Cersei doing a little bit of incest
bran is troubled but he's even more
troubled when Jaime pushes him off the
tower to keep
their secret things I do for love
paralyzing it Ned Arya and Sansa had
south to King's Landing while John heads
north to join the Nights Watch John
quickly proves himself a strong fighter
and befriends the heavyset and Cowardly
Samwell Tarly Collins Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch Junior Mormont takes a
shine to Jon and make some his personal
steward along with giving of his
family's heirloom sword made of highly
prized and rare Valyrian steel back at
Winterfell recovering brand Stark is
attacked by a stranger armed with a
dagger Catelyn comes to believe the
Lannisters are involved and heads to
King's Landing to tell Ned I know they
did the Lannisters in my bones I know it
Ned's already got his hands full dealing
with a difficult King and the other
members of King Robert's small Council
they include Petyr Baelish aka
Littlefinger the master of coin have
hoped to meet you for some time though
it's stopped the long-serving grand
maester pycelle Robert's younger brother
Renly Baratheon and Lord Varys a eunuch
who runs the Kings spy network there are
also all sorts of other colorful
characters including Joffrey's bodyguard
the Hound real names Sandor Clegane and
his even more ferocious and massive
brother named Gregor Clegane aka the
mountain they changed actors later we'll
keep you updated we also meet sir Loras
Tyrell the knight of the flowers who's
actually Renly Baratheon secret lover
scandal Catelyn arises in the capital
where she meets up with her childhood
friend Littlefinger how did you know I
was coming to King's Landing he tells
her that the dagger she found used to be
his I lost this dagger to whom Tyrion
Lannister
Ned meanwhile discovers that King Robert
has a number of bastard children stashed
around the city including Gendry a local
blacksmith's apprentice find anything
rubbish busted soon on her way back to
Winterfell from the capital Catelyn runs
into Tyrion and has him arrested for
what she believes is the attempted
murder of her son they head to Catelyn
sister Lysa Aaron's castle known as the
Eyrie and then all seven hells break
loose Tyrion demands a trial by combat
and a wily knight named bran volunteers
to be his champion bronwen's the fight
and they leave net is attacked in the
street by Jamie who then flees King's
Landing while recovering men figures out
the secret that Jon Arryn had discovered
and that presumably got him killed
sir sees children are not actually
Robert Baratheon
but were fathered by her brother Jamie
Joffrey Baratheon it's the blonde hair
that's the clue it sounds like something
King Robert would be furious about if he
weren't mortally wounded during a hunt
my fault he names Ned his regent and
protector of the realm before he dies
but Cersei straight-up ignores this and
declares that her son Joffrey is the new
king I wish to be crowned within the
fortnight Roberts brother Renly declares
himself the king of Westeros give me a
hundred swords you'll come on but Ned
suggests that Renly's older brother
Stannis would rightfully be the next in
line Stannis is your older brother Ned
refuses to swear loyalty to Joffrey and
is arrested your son has no claim to the
throne Renly and Loras flee the capital
and start assembling an army and Cersei
in the small council manipulates Sansa
into writing to Robb and asking him to
bend the knee to Joffrey
he must write to lady Catelyn and your
brother the eldest what's his name
hoping to save his family Ned makes a
false confession and says Joffrey is the
real true king I come before you to
confess my treason but Joffrey has him
killed anyway bring me his head Arya in
disguise heads north to the wall along
with Robert's bastard Gendry robb stark
assembles an army loyal to the Starks
from across the north who all agree that
they should declare independence from
the Lannisters and King's Landing
entirely why shouldn't we rule ourselves
again they declare Robb the king in the
north and begin a war for independence
and revenge Robb proves himself a
natural leader winning multiple battles
against the Lannisters and capturing
Jaime to use as a hostage in order to
win these victories Robb agrees to marry
the daughter of a crusty old lord named
Walder Frey he has a number he thinks
will be suitable in exchange for his
armies passage over the bridge that his
house controls remember this Tywin
Lannister patriarch of the Lannister
family is none too happy
with what's going on and begrudgingly
since Tyrion to King's Landing to serve
as hand of the king and get things in
order and that's pretty much it for
season oh wait that's right there's a
whole other continent in this show
yep we're going east to Essos where we
meet the two surviving children of the
Mad King viserys and danerys targaryen
you can retake what he sees as his
family's rightful throne in Westeros
Viserys has arranged for his sister to
marry the horse Lord Aquaman aka called
Drogo who commands an army of horse
warriors named the Dothraki we go home
with an army Daenerys is not happy about
this but doesn't really get a say in the
matter as a wedding gift she receives
three apparently petrified dragon eggs
from the mysterious eastern land of a
shine serving istan Eris's new advisor
and protector is Jorah Mormont a soap
your father for many years got to be
good I hope to always serve the rightful
king
Jorah is also secretly spying on the
Targaryen on behalf of Lord Varys and
tips off King Robert that Daenerys is
pregnant with a potential Targaryen heir
Viserys is unhappy that Daenerys is the
one getting the royal treatment and
threatens to kill her if Drogo doesn't
take his army west now to recapture the
Iron Throne I want the crown he promised
me so call Drogo kills him with boiling
gold
Daenerys takes it pretty well he's new
trapping Jorah prevents an assassination
attempt from Robert on Daenerys which
sells Drogo on the idea of invading
Westeros but during a fight Drogo is
wounded and dies Daenerys and Jorah are
abandoned by most of the Dothraki
huffing us was the throw was foul and
Daenerys loses her baby the boy did not
have however after walking into Drogo's
funeral pyre with the dragon eggs
Daenerys emerges unharmed with three
living baby dragons and that is the end
of season one it gets quicker from here
we promise I just introduced like 50
people
most of the second season is taken up
with the war of the five kings in which
a bunch of different Westerosi families
go to war over control of the Iron
Throne we can hopefully get through this
pretty quickly because as of right now
all of these Kings are either definitely
dead or very likely dead the first King
to drop is Renly Baratheon murdered by a
shadow demon conjured by his older
brother Stannis a grim man who's also
very grim Stannis is able to do this
with the help of the red woman
Melisandre a priestess for the Lord of
Light a God who gives visions to his
followers and fire require sacrifices
with fire lights the swords of his
warriors on fire he's big into fire I
have seen the pass to victory
Stannis is right-hand man is Davos
Seaworth a former smuggler who's not
sure about this whole fire priestess
thing Brienne of Tarth
Renly's loyal Kingsguard is blamed for
his death but flees his camp alongside
Catelyn Stark who would come to see
about a potential Renly Robb alliance
eventually Brienne swears fealty to
Catelyn who asked her to take Jaime
Lannister back to King's Landing and
exchange him for Arya and Sansa killing
Jaime Lannister would not buy life for
your children but returning him to
King's Landing may buy life for mine
Ridley's now widowed Margaery Tyrell is
you know kind of sad but really wants to
keep climbing up that social ladder do
you want to be a queen no I want to be
the queen Robb Stark meanwhile falls in
love with a nurse named to Lysa remember
that promise to marry one of Walder
Frey's daughters yet that's out the
window
much like bran back in King's Landing
Tyrion finally returns from his travels
along with a woman named Shay who long
story short is a prostitute Tyrion falls
in love with whom he also ultimately
kills with his bare hands that is a
whole other video
anyway as hand of the king Tyrion gets
to work and formulates an alliance with
the Martell family of Dorne I'm
brokering an alliance with house Martell
of Dorne
by sending Circe's daughter Myrcella
away to be married to one of their
princes Tyrion also discovers there's a
stockpile of wildfire which is kind of
like magical supercharged napalm in the
capital substance
so hot it melts wood stone even steel
eventually Stannis and his fleet attack
King's Landing come with me and take
this city and what comes to be known as
the Battle of the Blackwater Tyrion and
bran destroys Stannis's fleet with
wildfire but the army keeps on coming
The Hound frightened of all these flames
abandons his position and leaves King's
Landing the city the king Tyrion and the
Lannister soldiers manage to protect the
castle but not before Tyrion is brutally
scarred in the battle the rest of
Stannis's Force is wiped out when Tywin
Lannister arrives along with an
additional army courtesy of Marjorie's
family the powerful House Tyrell the
battle is over we have won Stannis
retreats back to Dragonstone to be grim
where Melisandre convinces him to keep
fighting Tyrion is relieved of his power
you are no longer a hand of the king and
the hand of the king position now goes
to Tywin himself thank you your grace
and by way of saying thanks for the army
Margaery Tyrell is now betrothed to
Joffrey and Sansa is no longer in line
to be married to the king okay let's
head up north to Winterfell where brand
has been having strange dreams about a
three-eyed raven and seeing through the
eyes of his direwolf summer more on that
later in need of more soldiers Robb
Stark dispatches Theon back to the Iron
Islands and his home of Pike to get his
father Balon Greyjoy to join his cause I
brought you a proposal from Bob stock
but Balin refuses and once instead to
attack the north while the Starks and
their allies are focused on fighting the
Lannisters
Theon flips allegiances and leads a band
of Raiders from house Greyjoy to take
control of Winterfell thank you your
castle bran and Rickon escape with
former wildling OSHA and Starks servant
slash chauffeurs slash mononym Hodor and
head north to the wall to meet up with
Jon Snow Roose Bolton of the dreadfort
one of Rob's most powerful allies offers
to send his bastard son Ramsay to retake
Winterfell
fionna hosts
with his cousin Theon's men turn on him
abandoned Winterfell which is then
burned and gives Theon over to the
Bolton army even further north several
members of the Nights Watch go searching
for the missing ranger Benjen stark
who's Ned Stark's brother at an ancient
landmark called the fist of the first
men they find a cache of weapons made of
a substance called dragon glass these
will be very important later Jon Snow
gets separated from the other Rangers
meets up with a Wilding named Ygritte
and becomes a spy for the Nights Watch
embedded with the army of Mance Rayder
the king-beyond-the-wall oh let's not
forget arya while travelling north out
of King's Landing and toward the wall
she meets up with a man named Jacques
and Hegar who's being held prisoner and
then that's the first make a friend yeah
he always talks funny like that
the Lannisters catch up with the party
kill arias friend take her sword needle
and take the entire group to the
Lannister held Harrenhal in the process
arya saves jack ins life jaqen
appreciative of arias help agrees to
kill three people for her as a mate good
man persistence my nose tree and he
ultimately helps arya and Guidry escaped
Harrenhal and go into friends with
through the gate at midnight jock and
offers to take Arya with him to the free
city of Braavos and teach her to be an
assassin like him but Arya doesn't want
to abandon her family so he gives her an
iron coin that she can use later to find
him and as jaqen H'ghar leaves he
reveals that he can magically change his
appearance he doesn't even need one of
those Mission Impossible masks that's it
that's a real time-saver on the other
side of the world Daenerys abandoned by
Drogo's men and near-death finds her way
to the city of Qarth a wealthy merchant
and a warlock their plot to steal our
dragons but she takes them out
and manages to get away with enough
valuables to buy a ship yeah that's
pretty much Daenerys in season two a lot
of season three takes place way up north
and Castle black and beyond so let's
start with the Nights Watch Jon Snow
makes it to the wildling camp and meets
tormund Giantsbane and
king-beyond-the-wall mance rayder he
convinces them that he's sincere about
joining their cause we'll need to find
you a new cloak man sins torment Jon
Ygritte and some others on a perilous
mission to climb over the wall and then
wait to attack Castle black from the
other side where they're less defended
on their way to the wall Jon and Ygritte
fall in love and do it in a cave but
once they're over the wall Jon refuses
to kill an old man who helps supply the
Nights Watch with horses
so the wildlings figure out that he's
not really on their side after all they
try to kill him even Ygritte but he
escapes on the other side of the wall
sam falls in love with a woman named
Kelly at the worst air B&B in Westeros
Craster's keep the other Nights Watch
brothers grow tired of Craster's lack of
hospitality and kill him Commander
Mormont dies in the scuffle and Sam and
Gilly run away on their way back to the
wall Sam manages to kill a white Walker
with a dagger made of dragonglass
they eventually make it back to Castle
black and warn everyone that the White
Walkers have returned meanwhile bran
stark and his company meet up with two
teens from house Reed Jojen and Meera
the reeds want to take brand north to
find the three-eyed raven from his
dreams
Jojen tells bran that he's a warg
meaning he can see through the eyes of
animals and control them you can get
inside his head here his eyes and bran
has the sight allowing him to see things
that are happening far away things that
haven't happened yet or thinks it
happened in the past bran sends his
brother and OSHA away and decides to
venture beyond the wall to find the
Raven Arya Stark is still on the run
with ginjury when they cross paths with
a group calling themselves the
Brotherhood without banners
it's run by beric Dondarrion the knight
who was sent way back in season one by
Ned Stark to track down the mountain
beric Dondarrion is now loyal to no
house and is in league with another
priest for the Lord of Light a drunk
named Thoris of me
purely by coincidence the Brotherhood
also has the hound captive and they put
him on trial for murder i sentence you
to trial by combat so he and beric
Dondarrion have a sword fight the hound
wins killing barrack in the process but
Thoreau Springs him back to life using
the Lord of Lights magic so the Hound
decides to take off Melisandre then
locates the group and takes ginjury so
she can sacrifice him and his Baratheon
Kings blood to the Lord of Light to aid
Stannis's cause arya takes the chance to
run away from the Brotherhood but is
captured by the Hound who's been waiting
for her and plans to take her back to
her family for a ransom Theon meanwhile
is being tortured for fun by Roose
Bolton's sadistic cruel bastard Ramsay
snow this torture includes cutting off
Theon spike broken by his captors Theon
now agrees to be Ramsay's pet with a new
name reek and speaking of house Bolton
one of their bannermen a guy named locke
intercepts Jaime and Brienne lay man of
house Bolton and takes them captive he
chops off Jaime's right hand as a show
of strength once they arrive at
Harrenhal Castle Jaime's injury is
treated by a disgraced former maester
named Qyburn who lost his position for
conducting illegal and questionable
experiments on people Roose Bolton
agrees to send Jaime to King's Landing
where he promises Brienne that he will
have the stark daughters released as
Catelyn Stark wished Stannis Baratheon
spends this entire season in his castle
at Dragonstone grimly brooding about his
loss at the Blackwater
when ser Davos finds out about MELAS on
just plan to sacrifice ginjury he frees
the boy and tells him to head for King's
Landing in a rowboat a trip that will
take at least a couple of seasons and
Kings Landing Joffrey is now enjoying
his engagement to Margaery Tyrell which
is really both to step up and to step
down for her Sansa tells Olenna Tyrell
the powerful matriarch of the wealthy
Tyrell family the truth about King
Joffrey he's but the wedding plans
continue anyway Tywin Lannister decides
to lock up the whole damn realm and
orders that Tyrion be married to Sansa
to secure the north and Cersei be
married to Loras Tyrell to secure the
south neither one of them is happy with
this arrangement and finally in Westeros
this robb stark and his are
they're starting to lose the war through
attrition and a loss of morale don't
have enough to make a difference have
you lost faith in our cause to secure
the men he needs to keep fighting he has
to make good with the man he
double-crossed Walder Frey I've come to
make my apologies my lord they come to
an agreement catlins brother and mere
Tully will marry Walters daughter Roslyn
and the phrase will receive Harrenhal as
further compensation on route to Edmund
yours wedding to Lisa reveals to rob
that she's pregnant but their happiness
is short-lived because as it turns out
Roose Bolton and Jaime Lannister were up
to something in their time together at
Harrenhal tell Robb Stark I'm sorry I
couldn't make his uncle's wedding the
Lannisters send their regards
immediately after the wedding ceremony
and Rob's public apology to Walder Frey
he's betrayed by both the phrase and
Bolton's their regards to Lisa
Robb and Catelyn are all murdered along
with most of their soldiers and even
Rob's direwolf gray wind for his
participation in what comes to be known
as the red wedding Roose Bolton becomes
warden of the north friend of the
Lannisters and architect of the most
shocking moment in Game of Thrones
history so far and finally we go east to
Essos
Daenerys uses the money she stole from
Qarth to travel to the slave city of a
stupor she promises to trade one of her
dragons in exchange for a slave army
known as the unsullied but the dragon
has different ideas and burns the Army's
owner alive
Daenerys frees the slaves and now has
the unsullied as a willing private army
led by the soldier grey worm she also
recruits a formerly enslaved translator
missin day to join the cause Daenerys
and the unsullied now advanced to a city
called un KY intending to free the
slaves there as well see Daenerys
mission is kind of shifted from just
conquering Westeros to also ridding the
world of slavery because she have to
dream big
um KY is protected by a mercenary group
called the second son's but one of them
Daario naharis is so impressed by
Daenerys Beauty that he turns on his
leaders kills the men who were sent to
assassinate Daenerys and brings the
second sons into her army they changed
actors later we'll keep you updated sir
Jorah Daario and grey worm go on a
daring raid to secure um KY after which
the city's freed slaves embrace Daenerys
as Misa meaning mother as season 4
begins we turn our attention back to
King's Landing we're planning for King
Joffrey's wedding to Margaery Tyrell is
deep under way among the guests is
Prince Oberyn Martell of Dorne brother
of King Aerys the second wife Elia he
wants revenge against the Lannisters in
the mountain for the rape and murder of
his sister and the murders of most of
her children in the aftermath of
Robert's rebellion at Joffrey's wedding
he drinks some poisoned wine and dies
but usually the death of a child is a
tragedy but you know what I'll give this
one a pass Cersei assumes Tyrion and his
wife Sansa must have been behind it
orders them both arrested Sansa manages
to get away and out of King's Landing
with some help from Littlefinger who was
working with the mastermind of Joffrey's
murder
Marjorie's grandmother Lady Olenna you
don't think I'd let you marry that beast
deal Littlefinger vows to keep Sansa
safe and takes her with him to the Vale
where he marries her aunt Lysa Arryn and
a season 1 mystery is solved as we
discovered that Littlefinger told Lysa
to kill her husband Jon Arryn so they
could be together and then send a letter
to the Starks blaming it on the
Lannisters
those tops and told me to pour them into
Jon's so in a way Littlefinger is really
the mastermind behind almost everything
that's happened in Westeros so far
anyway now that he's power married with
a firm grip on the veil lies the air in
the served her purpose
so Littlefinger pushes her out of the
moon door back in King's Landing Jaime
who has a new golden hand tasks Brienne
with finding Sansa iSchool by all the
calls that if told us well life admits
on the job he gives Brienne Oathkeeper a
Valyrian steel sword Tywin created by
melting down Ned Stark's sword ice he
also sends Tyrians and experienced
Squire Podrick along with her with
Joffrey dead his younger brother Tommen
is crowned the new king with Marjorie as
his eager new queen and waiting when we
marry I become yours this is also where
we meet Tommen's cats sir pounce a key
season four character Tyrion is put on
trial but he knows it's rigged against
him you will not speak unless called
upon so he goes with what worked for him
last time I demand a trial by combat
Oberyn Martell joins team Tyrion there
will be your champion with the mountain
representing the prosecution approaching
Oberyn also known as the red Viper
initially has the upper hand but the
mountain grabs him and smashes his head
in his hands like a grape the mountain
is horribly wounded in the fight but
maester Qyburn believes he could be
saved approaches move out of options
Jamie breaks tearing out of prison and
arranges with Lord Varys to sneak him
onto a ship bound for Essos but before
he leaves tearing goes to his father's
bedroom and kills him on the John with a
crossbow blunt but to the point Ari and
the Hound managed to avoid any trouble
back during the red wedding Massacre at
the twins so they head to the Vale but
are turned away after hearing about Lysa
Erin's death video and died three days
ago
Brienne and Podrick run across both of
them on the road you a knight which
leads to a knock-down drag-out fight
between Brienne and the Hound over who
wants to protect Arya more The Hound is
badly wounded and asks Arya to kill him
but she refuses Arya then goes on the
run and makes it to a port where she
uses the iron coin that jock and Hegar
gave her to book passage across the sea
to Braavos extremely far to the north at
the very top of the world we get our
first real look at the show's main
undead nemesis the night king able to
turn innocent babies into White Walkers
a bit south of there bran and his group
arrive at a tree he's seen in his
visions where they're attacked by
White's Jojen Reed is killed but bran
Meera and Hodor managed to make it into
a nearby cave where they are protected
by ancient creatures known as the
children of the forest bran meets the
three-eyed Raven who isn't Max von Sydow
yet but soon will be I've been watching
you all of you just a bit south of there
Jon Snow returns to Castle black which
is good because mance rayder's army
Sage's a massive assault just as Jon
warned them they would yeah they have
Giants it's the North during the battle
Ygritte seems to get the drop on Jon
but she's killed by a boy named Ali
eventually the Nights Watch is
successful at holding the invasion off
but Mance's army is still pretty big and
plans to come back when out here to
conquer we are here to hide behind your
wall that is until Stannis Baratheon
shows up with a newly aquired army
courtesy of a loan from the iron bank of
Braavos who has switched their
allegiance from the Lannisters to the
real Baratheon's Stannis routes the
wildling forces and takes Mance Rayder
prisoner finally far to the east and
Eris and her armies arrive in the final
slave City Marine after liberating
Marine Daenerys finds out just how
difficult it is to keep the peace and
prevent the return of slavery in three
cities so she agrees to delay her trip
to Westeros it appears my liberation of
slavers Bay and getting
his plan she also discovers that sir
Jorah Mormont had been serving as a
Baratheon spy he'd be treating me and
banishes him from marine and all other
slave cities for life
sir Jorah is sad season 5 opens with a
flashback showing a young Cersei and her
friend visiting a witch in the woods
near Casterly Rock
future the witch tells her that one day
she'll be Queen and will have three
children but they will all die during
her lifetime and she'll be replaced by a
younger and more beautiful Queen so
she's got that going for it which is
nice jumping forward to the present at
least part of the prophecy comes true
with the marriage of Tommen and Margaery
Sarah sees been demoted to Queen Mother
but is still trying to run the capital
herself and head off the increasingly
powerful Tyrells this includes forming
an alliance with a religious group on
the rise in King's Landing called the
sparrows and their leader the high
Sparrow initially this works up pretty
well for Cersei as the high Sparrow has
both sir Loras and Margaery Tyrell
arrested but then Cersei loses control
of the group and ends up arrested
herself on charges including incest and
the murder of King Robert so it's pretty
serious as punishment Cersei is forced
to confess her sins and walk naked
through the streets of King's Landing
while this lady yells shame at her
there is one bright spot though when her
walk is over Qyburn introduces her to
the newly resurrected mountain a silent
8 foot tall zombie in gold armor who
lives to do her bidding
meet Jaime Lannister is not around for
any of this because he's off in Dorne
electrifly's after getting a threatening
message from oberyn's lover ilaria Jamie
takes Bronn with him to rescue his
daughter Myrcella don't forget a few
seasons ago Tyrion sent Marcella to
Dorne to be married Prince Doran of
Dorne agrees to send Myrcella back to
King's Landing
if the alliance between the Iron Throne
and Dorne is to continue that engagement
must stand as they leave for the return
trip however ilaria goes rogue and
poisons Marcella to death that's two
Baratheon child poisonings in a row
across the sea Arya arrives in Braavos
to learn the ways of the many-faced God
from Jackie and Hagar and his lovely
assistant Jockin tells us she has to
become no.1 and she pretends to know
what that means
who are you then no one eventually Arya
runs into her old enemy Meryn Trant the
Kingsguard who killed her teacher Syrio
Forel and starts crossing more names off
her list meanwhile Tyrion and Varys
arrive overseas and the former master
whispers convinces his new traveling
companion to go meet with Daenerys I
believe men of talent have a part to
play in the war to come
Tyrion eventually makes his way to
Daenerys with surgery who has kidnapped
him as a peace offering
Daenerys agrees to take on Tyrion as an
advisor but once more censured Jorah
away Tyrion is won over by Daenerys has
plans to not just up in the way Westeros
works but break the system all together
I'm not going to stop the wheel
I'm going to break the wheel but things
are falling apart in Mereen the city's
experiencing an uprising by former
slavers calling themselves the sons of
the harpy hoping to keep the peace she
agrees to reopen the fighting pits
gladiator like arenas where men fight
for sport the sons of the harpy staged a
revolt and begins slaughtering everyone
Daenerys is about to be killed when
she's saved by drogon her biggest and
let's face it favorite dragon who flies
away with her on his back surgery
Mormont who keeps turning up like a bad
penny and new Daario go to look for
dragon headed north we're going to find
her that's what I have to go
while Tyrion stays behind to run things
in marine we the viewers see that she's
eventually set down and then immediately
taken prisoner by another group of dis
Rocky
good job Shogun way to help things are
also going sideways in Westeros where
Littlefinger has arranged for Sansa to
marry Ramsay Bolton making her a
powerful figure in the north stop being
a bystander Jaime so funny
Ramsay is of course a horrible person
and brutalizes his new wife while
continuing to traumatize Theon slash
reek eventually both of them decide
they've had enough and escaped the
castle together at the wall Jon's
elected the new Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch becoming the 990 8th man to
hold the title but who's counting among
his first actions is to seek an alliance
with the wildlings offering to give them
land south of the wall in exchange for
help fighting the White Walkers make
peace to save your people this does not
go over well with a lot of his brothers
who still think of the free folk as
their enemy it's loaded villages Jon is
also losing allies quickly as Sam leaves
for old town with Gilly where he's gonna
study to become a maester Jon
tormund and some other brothers and
wildlings travelled north of the wall to
the wildling settlement at hardhome in
an attempt to keep a huge group of
wildlings from becoming part of the
night king's army the White Walkers
don't care if a mountains free folk or
crow we're all the same to them meat for
their army but while they're there
they're attacked by White Walkers and
whites John discovers for himself that
dragonglass
and Valyrian steel can
both take out white walkers but it's a
rout nonetheless the battle ends with
John and some wildlings escaping but the
night king resurrecting all of the dead
to serve in his army so it's kind of a
mixed bag
Stannis plans to begin his conquest of
Westeros by attacking the Bolton's at
Winterfell
but Ramsay gets the drop on him and
burns most of his supplies and siege
weapons so Stannis does the only thing
he could think of he allows Melisandre
to sacrifice his daughter Shireen to the
Lord of Light
but whoops Stannis's army is still
decimated by the Bolton's forces after
his devastating loss Brienne finds him
and executes him to avenge the death of
Renly I was there when he was mounted by
shadow to the old face at least we're
pretty sure that's what happened it's
off screen but we do know that Davos and
Melisandre survived and returned to
Castle black where John's brothers are
so upset at his alliance with the
wildlings they stab him to death lavash
yeah even Olly this kid is a monster oh
yeah and there's no brand this season
he's busy in a tree studying for his
Raven midterms
thankfully John's not dead for too long
season six opens with wildlings and
brothers sympathetic to John putting
down the insurgency and retaking control
of Castle black then Melisandre who we
find out actually looks hundreds of
years old and uses magic to appear young
and beautiful praise to the Lord of
Light and brings John back from the dead
John then hangs the traitors who led the
revolt against him and leaves the Nights
Watch by what she's ended having
fulfilled his oath to serve until his
death gotta love those technicalities
meanwhile Brienne and Podrick meet up
with the freshly escaped Theon and Sansa
Theon takes off to return to his family
and the Iron Islands they will keep you
safe for the night while the rest of
them head for Castle black as Winterfell
is still held by the Bolton's well to be
specific held by Ramsay Bolton who's the
new Lord Bolton after murdering his
father along with dad's new wife and
their baby boy Ramsay is so evil guys
just really really bad news reunited
with his sister Sansa John begins
amassing an army to retake Winterfell
including many of the minor northern
houses and this actual minor Lyanna
Mormont
yeah just want my allegiance you want my
fighting ring Littlefinger who de facto
controls the Eyrie due to his outsized
influence on young Robin Arryn offers
the Knights of the Vale to help this
isn't directly plot connected but you
should also know that tormund kind of
has a thing for Brienne okay it's time
for the so called battle of the bastards
Ramsay kicks it off by killing a captive
Rickon stark with an arrow
serpentine kid always got to run
serpentine this causes Jon to make some
possibly unwise tactical decisions but
just when all seems lost
Sansa Littlefinger and the Knights of
the Vale show up and they retake
Winterfell
Sansa feeds Ramsay to his own dogs for
revenge yeah get him also no Davos
discovers the truth about what happened
to princess Shireen I loved that girl
like she was my own and demands that Jon
allowed to execute Melisandre Jon sends
her away instead and tells her never to
return to the north meanwhile the other
lords of the north pledged themselves to
Jon Snow the king
in the newel yeah that's how you pledged
yourself north of the wall we meet back
up with bran who's been training to look
into the past with the three-eyed Raven
who's now in his final form as Max von
Sydow bran sees a few important visions
including the creation of the first
white Walker I mean listen was a
different time okay people were less
sensitive about turning humans into
frost monsters and in yet another vision
bran sees the night king who becomes
aware of his presence this alerts the
white walkers to the location of the
cave which is then attacked by the
knight king's army mirrors instructions
in the present to hold the door for her
and brand combined with brands time
travel awarding powers end up being the
origin story for why Hodor compulsively
repeats the phrase Hodor but anyway
Hodor dies very soon this is also our
maximum seed ow and summer the direwolf
meet their untimely ends or if you're a
white Walker they're perfectly timed
ends outside of the cave Meera and bran
are about to be killed by whites when
they're saved by a disfigured Benjen
stark remember him from season one he
takes Meera and bran back toward the
wall and this is where brand touches a
weirwood tree and has yet another vision
but this is an important one the true
story behind Jon Snow we see that Ned
Stark discovered his sister Lyanna
giving birth to a son by Rhaegar
Targaryen before dying knowing that King
Robert would kill this baby if he found
it Ned claims it as his own bastard
child naming him Jon Snow
so Jon is of noble blood he's half stark
and half Targaryen and I bet you didn't
see that coming unless you were on the
Internet ever before this aired okay
let's head south for the odds and ends
by the time Theon returns to the Iron
Islands he let you go
his uncle Euron has also come back and
killed his father bail on Euron has
crowned the new king and vows to marry
Daenerys Targaryen and use her dragons
to claim control of Westeros
I wasn't born to be king I paid the iron
price in the aftermath Theon and Yara
flee but yeren vows to build a new fleet
and go after them meanwhile Sam Gilly
and newborn baby Sam stop at the end
Starly home on their way to the citadel
for Sam's Meister training and this
isn't really important except to note
that Sam's dad is a dick and Sam steals
the family's Valyrian steel sword hearts
bein as payback once they arrived in old
town dozens of white Ravens are released
signaling the official start of the long
winter across the seeds an heiress is
taken to Vice doth rack where she
immediately burns the entire Dothraki
leadership alive Daenerys declares
herself the new leader of the Dothraki
and heads home to marine where she
quickly puts down the revolt against her
just in time to receive a visit from the
Greyjoy's sublimes run sisters defeat
Eidos took the iron islands he asked you
to give them back
they provide her with a fleet of ships
which she graciously accepts and uses to
set sail for Westeros before departing
for her homeland she also names Tyrion
her hand of the Queen meanwhile Aria
continues her faceless man training
which is like 98% stick fighting
but eventually her strong wills lead
jaqen to give his lovely assistant
permission to kill her but the assistant
loses and she's killed jack and tells
arya that she's ready to join the
faceless kids club finally a good but
she says she's tired of being no-one and
intends to go back to being Arya Stark
of Winterfell
this news causes jock into I don't know
it's smart kinda it's not his face he's
still feeling it out back in Westeros
she gets her red wedding revenge
posing as a servant in the Frey
household and feeding Walder Frey a pie
containing his two sons and then
executing him also back in Westeros we
find out that the Hound is still alive
doing a lay lotv Incredible Hulk kind of
thing eventually he teams up with Thoris
of mere and beric Dondarrion it helps
them execute some rogue members of the
Brotherhood without banners meanwhile
back in King's Landing Cersei has had it
with both the high Sparrow and the
Tyrells so she and Qyburn do the natural
thing and detonate wildfire under the
great Sept Deering lorises trial this
explosion kills everyone inside
including the high Sparrow and every
Tyrell not played by Dame Diana Rigg
while Cersei relishes her victory Tommen
seeing that his queen is dead
his city is partially destroyed commits
suicide and all of Circe's children died
just as the wits foretold and sorry I've
always just wanted to say just as the
witch foretold in the aftermath of the
violence Cersei is crowned the new queen
oh and over in Dorne
ilaria sand and the red Vipers daughters
the sand snakes assassinate Prince Doran
and declare war freakin Dorne am i right
okay here we are the second to last
season and the last season for this cram
it we're almost at the end and honestly
this is further into the story than
george RR martin ever made it so give
yourselves a hand
aria is all set to go to King's Landing
and kill Cersei but when she finds out
that her family has retaken Winterfell
she heads there instead in the woods she
sees Nymeria her old direwolf but the
animals got native and prefers running
wild and living with the pack you know
it's like a metaphor in old town Sam
does a lot of reading and meets up with
Jorah Mormont who's now infected with a
deadly disease called greyscale Sam
cures Jorah and Jorah heads back to
Daenerys to serve his queen she takes
him back because the guy just won't quit
Daenerys arrives in Westeros with her
armies and her dragons and everybody
else at Dragonstone which is empty since
Stannis Baratheon abandoned it for his
failed campaign in the North there she's
visited by Melisandre who suggests Sam
meeting with Jon Snow and I'm stand
before you and tell you the things that
happen to him
Tyrion seconds the motion so they extend
an invitation Jon Snow decides to go
against sonses advice and leaves her in
charge as warden of the north in his
stead after he leaves Mira and bran make
it back from their travels but bran has
been changed seemingly forever by his
powers and has emotionally disconnected
almost completely I could never be Lord
of anything
he barely even reacts when Mira tells
him she's leaving to go back home man
evil no I don't that's cold
I mean obviously because it's the north
but it also lacks feeling around this
time arya also returns to Winterfell and
hugs everyone Littlefinger is also
hanging around the castle and generally
being a creep he tries to drive a wedge
between Arya and Sansa for his own
benefit
she could want she could want me dead
but it doesn't work they turn the tables
on him and put him on trial the conflict
between the Starks and the Lannisters it
was you who started it do you deny it
and Sansa finds him guilty thank you for
all your many lessons Lord Baelish I
will never forget them
alright it takes care of the execution
herself with his own Valyrian steel
dagger the stark girls coming this fall
to ADC John arrives at Dragonstone and
is reunited with Tyrion Lannister who he
hasn't seen since they hung out at the
wall all the way back in season one
remember that I just started talking
crazy it's been a long road
Melisandre says that she is now going to
return to volantis in the east but she
does predict that both she and Varys are
destined to die in Westeros you gotta
wonder if that's gonna you know pay off
later on even though Jon struggles to
convince Daenerys of the white Walker
threat she lets him start mining for
dragonglass below the castle anyway
he's also able to bond pretty easily
with drogon who perhaps senses his
Targaryen ancestor
you know what I'm getting out of myself
let's go to King's Landing where the
Lannisters are doing what they do best
paying their debts Jaime Lannister
randyll Tarly Sam's dad the jerk and
Bronn lead a force that takes the
Tyrells Castle Highgarden Olenna Tyrell
is there and Jaime allows her to drink
poison for a quick merciful death right
before she goes she confesses to him
that it was her who ordered the hit on
Joffrey Cersei takes the news well she
died screaming
see the Lannisters plan to use the money
they're looting from the Tyrells to pay
off their debts to the iron bank once
those are taken care of the bank will
back the Lannisters and hiring the
golden company the largest mercenary
force in the world to retain their power
but Daenerys her dragons and the
Dothraki attacked the wagon train as it
moves the loot from Highgarden back to
King's Landing
both bran and Jaime's survived the
attack somehow Sam's dad and brother
Randall and dick and Tarly are captured
by Denari
and after refusing to bend the knee
burned by her dragons Tyrians not crazy
about this strategy don't beheading
entire speaking of Tyrion he has Davos
sneak him into King's Landing hoping to
make some kind of peace accord with
Jaime you can ask yourself ultimately
their unsuccessful but Davos does manage
to find Gendry while he's there
remember Gendry from that boat he's back
in an entirely different boat Jamie
tells Cersei that he met secretly with
Tyrion and about the army of the Dead
but she already knows all this dragon
dragon queen she also tells him that
she's pregnant who uses his father yeah
back at Dragonstone Jon decides the only
way to prove to everyone that the White
Walkers are really really for real and
he's super super serial about this is to
go beyond the wall
get a white and bring it back to show
everyone I'm the only one who is fooled
the only one here who knows going along
for the ride are a renewed and
invigorated Sir Jorah forgiving his
trespasses plus torment and some other
wildlings
Gendry Thoris and barrack and their new
friend the Hound during the harsh
journey
Thoros is mauled to death by an undead
bear but the snow aside squad does
manage to bag itself a white in doing so
they discover that killing a white
Walker also destroys all of the white
serving them which is good to know they
get pinned down and have ginjury run
back to Eastwatch on his own for help
you're the Fosters no no and I'm not
sure how the timing works on this one
but Daenerys flies up with her dragons
to save everyone but the night king
manages to take out Vissarion with an
iced javelin with some help from Benjen
Stark John and his group managed to get
away but benjin sadly is killed in the
fighting again I guess geez this guy has
more lives than a cat even worse for
Humanity's sake Viserion comes back to
life as an undead ice dragon that's
gonna leave a mark
Daenerys now fully convinced of the
threat of the White Walkers vows that
she and John will destroy the night King
together it's also pretty obvious to
everyone watching that these two have
feelings for one another which is gonna
be super weird in just a couple more
minutes
okay almost there so just about every
living major character from the show
thus far formally and officially meets
up in King's Landing to talk about the
white Walker situation tyrion reconnects
with bran and Podrick it's good to see
you again yeah you too
Brienne and King's Landing at santa's
request makes her peace with the Hound
I'm Sammy trying to protect her
and it's all very nice present surprise
in an unpleasant situation until they
show everybody the white you're on just
straight-up freaks out and leaves
immediately for the Iron Islands this is
the only thing I've ever seen so
terrified when Cersei finds out Jon has
already declared for the Targaryen she
leaves the meeting the Dead will come
with first enjoy dealing with me we will
deal with whatever is left of you
Tyrion tries to reason with her I would
not care and figures out that she's
pregnant but once he leaves Cersei
reveals the full scope of her plans to
Jaime she's really in league with Joran
who's off with his fleet pickin up the
golden company once everyone else has
exhausted themselves fighting the dead
she's going to use her forces to wipe
out whoever's left and stay in power
Jaime thinks this is crazy and
dishonourable and crazy dishonourable so
he takes off leaving King's Landing just
as the first snow begins to fall
Theon remember Theon pledges his
allegiance to Jon then returns to the
Iron Islands fights this guy hard enough
to prove himself and raises an army to
save his sister yarr from the clutches
of his uncle Euron yeah
Daenerys and John set sail together for
Winterfell and totally like get it on
along the way
Tyrion gets wise to what they're up to
and seems concerned or perturbed
he seems conserved and this may be why
Sam and Gilly have stumbled on some very
telling clues about Jon's real identity
and head to Winterfell these clues and
brands greensight are all our heroes
need to put together the truth Jon isn't
really my father Phil Rhaegar Targaryen
had his first marriage to Elia Martell
annulled by the High Septon so that he
could marry Lyanna stark making their
baby Jon Snow a legitimate highborn lord
named which also makes Jon Daenerys his
nephew ha you've been thrown these two
they just got thrown and as if that's
not enough in the season's final scene
eastwatch-by-the-sea is attacked by the
night king riding an undead Viserion ice
dragon together they take out a big
chunk of the wall as beric Dondarrion
and tormund Giantsbane look on in horror
and the White Walkers begin to cross
into Westeros so that's pretty much
everything you need to know from all
seven seasons of Game of Thrones and
roughly the same time you need to watch
one episode we've been here for some
time
and if we could get george RR martin to
work at this pace maybe we wouldn't have
to wonder if the show and the books are
gonna end the same way thanks for
watching and now our cram has ended oh
oh or how about this this cram was dark
and full of terrors alright one more a
cram astir always pays their debts ok
I'm clearly delirious so it's time to go
see you next time